this is a disaster
everybody's already mad at us
Machiavelli said it's better to be
feared than loved
well I choose love nobody loves or fears
you people don't think about you at all
sure they do what do you think people
think about you I don't know probably
I'm a good person who was raised in a
loving family and I'm kind and a good
listener and I'm going places you know
this isn't the end of the road for me
that I'm wise beyond my years and still
handsome as a teen and at the end of the
day I'm just trying my best because
that's all anyone can do it that's crazy
world somebody's been keeping us prayed
she do every time I go to the bathroom
no shirt you on this the email didn't
say but this can't be accurate it says
you've got like 30 times a day I have a
tiny bladder okay it's a weakness and I
don't want it to define me tiny bladder
eh I wouldn't worry about it your
defining characteristic will always be
your huge ass somebody's shirt Jake on a
spreadsheet of every time he goes P it
has to be someone I pass in the way to
the bathroom it's probably somebody mad
about the desk censors I've been getting
tons of complaints really who's been
complaining about me that's strictly
confidential
but what I can tell you is everyone wait
where are you going where the do
you think
[Music]
look out everybody big brother's
watching what makes you think it's Baron
sweat she goes back four months barons
had it out for me ever since he found
out I had it out for him but here's the
thing I only had it up for him because
he had it out for me he's on the move I
got eyes on him
text me the moment he gets back to his
desk got it sorry and I'll man the fort
here
you